colombia superó las 40 mil muertes por
kobe 19 y registró la cifra más alta de
nuevos contagios desde la llegada del
virus al país en marzo el presidente
iván duque aseguró que el aumento se
debe a los festejos del día de las
velitas el 7 de diciembre una
celebración tradicional que todos los
años reúne a amigos y familiares
porque van a correr
por las aglomeraciones que se pudieron
presentar en los hogares en el día de
las velitas
y por supuesto vemos sus consecuencias
catorce días después diez días después
dos días después
y yo creo que aquí el mensaje tiene que
ser de autor
aún así en plena temporada de fin de año
no se prevé nuevo cierre si el gobierno
apuesta por el autocuidado en pleno
repunte de casos
duke anunció un plan de vacunación
dividido en cinco fases en las tres
primeras le dará prioridad a los
trabajadores de la salud en primera
línea de batalla contra el hobbit 19 y a
los mayores de 80 años en la segunda
etapa a los colombianos de 60 a 79 años
y los demás trabajadores de la salud y
en la tercera a personas de 16 a 59 años
y profesores de escuelas
este mal trato diferente riesgo de
incluso de salud mental
y urgente
los profesores sean vacunados para poder
entrar
para posibilidad
escuelas y colegios para poder
con efectos sobre la salud y sobre la
propia educación la vacunación empezaría
en las primeras semanas de enero y se
dio a conocer luego de que el presidente
de duke firmará contratos con las
farmacéuticas astrazéneca y fisher 10
millones de dosis con la primera y 10
millones con la segunda mientras que 20
millones de dosis llegarían al país a
través de la estrategia kóvacs pero aún
no se sabe la fecha en febrero 10
millones de personas recibirán la
primera dosis en un país que alcanza los
casi 50 millones de habitantes